hi there take a look at this variant of
the game
rock paper scissors uh it's like
usual rock paper scissors except with
the added complexity
that when either player chooses scissors
then the rewards and the losses are
doubled
so for example you see right here player
1 chooses
rock and player 2 chooses scissors
so both the reward for player 1
and the loss for player 2 are double
the size now you might know that in
original rock paper scissors the optimal
strategy
is to play one third of each of the
three choices at any time so you
basically take a fair
three-sided coin dice does that exist
i'm not sure um and you throw it and
whatever
side is up that's what you play
however here since one of the options is
different
the sort of optimal strategy shifts and
interestingly
it shifts as follows what you want to do
is you want to play
rock and paper both with a 0.4
probability and you want to play
scissors with only
0.2 probability that is pretty
interesting
uh you might in intuitively conclude
that
you want to go more where there are more
rewards
to be had but of course also you lose
more so you might also conclude well it
doesn't make a difference ultimately
but why does the why does the sort of
optimal strategy shift such that you
want to decrease
your likelihood of playing scissors
let's just quickly
analyze this game before we jump into
the paper because this game is sort of
a microcosm of what the paper of today
is about so the paper of today
is called combining deep reinforcement
learning and
search for imperfect information games
by noam brown anton buchten adam lehrer
and chi chen gong of facebook ai
research
so this paper brings basically what
alphago or alpha zero has done
for perfect information games it brings
this to the domain
of imperfect information games and we'll
see
what the difficulties are in this and
what can be done
to solve it and not only do they have an
algorithm but they have
the interesting theoretical results that
under
some conditions namely under the
condition that neural networks do
something useful
will actually converge to nash
equilibriums um
in these games so that is pretty cool so
practical
and theoretical paper right here um
as always if you like content like this
don't hesitate to
share it out and tell me what you think
in the comments
this is not my field so i might get
quite
a bit of stuff wrong right here
uh also if you haven't seen the the
negranu
poker challenge so it's i think it's the
last video i did
be sure to check that out just to see
how you have to
think about situations like this all
right let's get back to this
uh rock paper scissors example right
here
interestingly to note is that these
these dashed lines here
means that player two cannot decide
which of these states they're in
so player two doesn't know what states
are in for player two this is all
basically the same state
it'd be really easy right if player one
plays first
and then player two sees what player one
does and then they
they just act they always win however
player two doesn't so they have to sort
of decide what to do
independent of which state they're in uh
especially this is a
this is a symmetric game right this is a
two player
game because that's two players it's
zero sum because whenever
one player wins a reward the other
player loses the same reward
and um it is also it is
that makes it symmetric so all the both
players play at the same time though
that is not necessary in general but
here it's the case
all right so this means in this
particular case whatever strategy
player one has player two must have as
well so we'll just do the analysis for
player one
so let's say you deviate from this
optimal strategy right we claim that
this here
is the optimal strategy uh playing 20
of scissors let's say player one doesn't
believe it
player one deviates from it and says nah
there is so much reward there i'm gonna
get some more of that so they
upped this right they up this to like
let's say point
uh i don't know 0.33 like doing the
classic one-third or even higher right
they up this
go more scissors okay and
they probably want to take this mass
because they have to take it from
somewhere they probably want to take
this
from rock and paper let's say they just
take it equally from rock and paper
towards scissors to up the to up the
probability that they play scissors so
from paper and from rock they go towards
scissors
now player two
observes this right they can just play
against player one for a while or
what we're going to assume is that
everyone announces their strategy
publicly
uh it's the same thing you can just
observe someone for a while
or they can just announce their strategy
um
it's we'll treat this equally so player
two observes player one
playing scissors too often so player two
knows they are very often in this
situation right here
in this right state they can't directly
observe but they infer
i must be very often in this right
rightmost state
where player one chooses scissors and
therefore
you see player two's payoffs it's zero
here
minus two here and two here so they'll
say well
i or also have this optimal strategy of
0.4.4.2
what i can do is i can simply knowing
that i'm
a lot in this state i can simply take
some
mass from paper and put it on rock so i
play rock
way more often and i reduce
the amount i play paper right scissors
doesn't matter but
now i lose 2 less often
and i win 2 much more often and player 1
in turn loses 2 much more often and wins
much less often right so player 1 wanted
to get more reward
but they're sort of being punished by
player two for playing this too
often now you can say well it player one
can do the same thing
knowing that player two plays rock too
often now right they've taken away mass
from paper towards rock
knowing that player 2 has taken rook
player 1 knows that either they're here
or they're here right and in this case
player 1 can say all right uh you play
rock too often
obviously if i play scissors then i'm
going to
i'm going to lose but i've already
decided i want to play scissors much
more so they're trying to make it up
right here so what they can do in this
case is they can say
when i play paper i win one instead of
if i play rock two i win zero so i know
player two is playing rock
way more often than they should so i'm
going to punish player two by playing
paper more often so let's erase this
arrow let's say we play scissors
sorry we play scissors no let's not
erase this we play scissors by moving
from rock
and we also move from rock to paper like
we're almost never playing rock we're
just playing scissors
more often because that's what we
started with and we're playing
also now paper more often so now
we basically do the same thing that
player 2 did to us
we are upping the likelihood of this
thing happening and
and decreasing the likelihood of this
thing happening so now we can say
now i also i play paper more often
um now i i also win more often here
and you lose more often but you see
because the rewards are
doubled over here the fact that player
two can achieve
this is much more meaningful
than the fact that player one can
achieve this
okay and that's why uh
player one will be punished harder for
deviating here
so that's sort of how you reason about
these strategies so if player one
will play this point two too often um
they will be punished harder than player
for deviating in response to that and
the same counts for
the symmetric part this is a
very important concept right here
namely you can see player two
strategy depends on player one strategy
even though you could conceptualize this
game of player one plays a move
and then they play a move but they don't
show it yet
right they play a move they take like a
picture of their hand
doing rock paper scissors and they just
don't show the picture yet
and then player two plays a move so now
we are basically back in we're in this
game
where it's sequential in nature and
usually in a sequential game you can
just do a sub game analysis
so you can just say okay and do a sub
game analysis but the the subgame
analysis depends
on the strategy of player 1 because you
don't know
the situation this is different than
a full information game and this is
illustrated
right here so they say usually
what something like alpha zero does is
you are game starts here right and then
you have two actions
to take you maybe take this action okay
now your opponent has two action
maybe they take this action all right
and now you have
two actions again which one do you take
what what something like deep q learning
or
actor critic learning would do is they
would simply put a neural network here
they would look at this state and they
would simply tell you which action to
pick
like this action right here sounds good
to the neural network
in contrast to that alpha zero if i draw
the same situation right here
alpha zero what it will do is
it will say well i could do this or i
could do this
if i do the left thing then i'm going to
have
my opponent's gonna have two options
they could do this or they could do that
if they do the left thing again and so
you get the idea
it sort of goes down the tree and it
does this over here right
sorry this should be so
it goes down the tree i'm stupid
and it evaluates it kind of
calculates ahead it uses its internal
simulator to look ahead
and it could technically do this until
it reaches the end
and then it would know if it reaches the
end state every time here
it would no it could simply backwards
calculate which one
is the best option for me to do right
now however
this game is often very very deep so the
tree
the depth here is often so deep that you
can't
solve the whole game so what alpha zero
does instead is it says
i'm not going to play until the end i'm
going to play a
certain amount ahead right i'm going to
think
some limited depth ahead and i know
alpha 0 does this adaptively but
bear with me i'm going to think some
limited
depth d ahead so here in this case d is
equal to two because we think
two layers ahead and then at the end
i'm going to replace everything that
comes after with a single value
that indicates how good this is for me
okay
so and this thing right here is very
hard to get
of course if you knew how good anything
is for you then you have solved the game
but alpha zero at this point the neural
network comes in
right it this is a neural network it's a
black box
so it simply asks for each one of these
states
how valuable do you think that is okay
and so on so it asks for each state the
neural network how valuable
that particular node is and then it does
the same backwards calculation
so we've sort of substituted going to
the
end of the game by the neural network
but it is still more powerful than
asking the neural network at the very
beginning
like we do here okay the the power comes
from
combining the learning this is this is
the learning
and the search this here is the search
right so this is what alpha zero does
and this is what this paper does
for imperfect information games so
imperfect information games is when you
don't know a particular thing about the
game
at any point so there's hidden
information like in poker
and the problem is right here if you do
the same thing for this game right here
and you look from
player one's perspective and you say
okay uh
this game is very deep actually it's
just too deep right
but let's assume that's too deep for you
and you want to replace
you want to say okay i'm just going to
look ahead d equals one that's all i can
afford
i go ahead and at the end i'm going to
ask my neural network
what the value here is and the neural
network
will tell you accurately that the value
at each of these nodes is zero so the
average value
if you can see right here the average
value of each of these nodes is
zero uh depending of course on how
player two acts but
in this case it's zero so as player one
this information will not lead you to
the correct optimal
conclusion the correct optimal
conclusion being this point four point
four point two
okay player one like it's indifferent
any strategy could work here right um if
there is some regularization it'll
probably come to the point
the one-third one-third one-third right
since all the values are
equal um it might conclude it's probably
best if i
distribute my actions or something so
you can see the problem
right here and the problem is that this
value
right here it depends on the strategy
of player one okay the
and this is something that alpha zero
has no concept on
for alpha zero the value of a node
only ever depends on what comes
downstream
in imperfect information game the value
of a node
also depends on what has happened
upstream so on the strategy of the
upstream events and that is
as i said that is that is quite
important
also for alpha zero once i have
evaluated a game tree
and determined the value of a node like
this
i can evaluate the same game tree again
and the value is going to be the same
but
for the same reason because the value
depends upstream the value of this node
right here
depending on upstream if i change my
strategy
so if here i determine either action one
or action two with a certain probability
if
this search process results in a result
that tells me this is how often you
should pick action one and that's
different
from what i searched with right then all
of these values down here are going to
change
and i can basically search again so
these are the problems of
imperfect information games that we're
going to tackle so you see this poker
thing is sort of a microcosm and this
was
already half of the paper if you
understood
why exactly searching um
using kind of a value estimator with
this combined with this tree search
is a problem in imperfect information
games
so let's quickly go through the abstract
then we're going to have to define
a few terms and then we can go into this
algorithm the algorithm is called
rebel it's a general framework for
self-play reinforcement learning and
search that provably converges to a nash
equilibrium in any two-player
zero sum game okay
it says that in the simpler setting of
perfect information games
rebel reduces to an algorithm similar to
alpha zero
and they say we also show
rebel achieves superhuman performance in
heads-up no limit texas hold'em
poker while using far less domain
knowledge than any prior poker ai
so last video i've had a comment uh
which is correct that is not
the best uh holdem ai out there as far
as i can tell
however it is a very performant one
that uses very little domain knowledge
of poker so it
like alpha zero removed basically all
domain knowledge
out of the games it played this right
here
i think the domain knowledge is to the
extent of
it is given a limited set of bet
sizes even though it's kind of no limit
told them where you can bet whatever you
want
um it's given sort of a limited bet
limited size
of bed sizes like half the pot
full pot two times the pot and so on
in order to make the actions discrete i
think that's
just easier for this algorithm but in
any case the algorithm is applicable
pretty much
anywhere where you have a two player
zero sum
uh imperfect information game or perfect
information
okay so let's shortly
go over a little bit of background
so we're going to need some terms right
here
the first term we're going to need is
what's called a world state
so a world state is the state
of the world i know easy easy but
it's quite important that to see that
in poker what is the world state so in
heads up now let me told them
there are your cards you get two your
opponent gets
two cards right and then there are board
cards
like at at the end there are five but
um maybe there are only three or they're
none yet depends on the state of the
game
so the board cards you know this is
maybe an ace a king
an eight you know your two hole cards
which is maybe an ace and an ace but you
don't know
your opponent's cards okay we're also
going to assume
that the actions are always public
for the purposes of this video they
don't
not not necessarily for rebel the
algorithm but
for us let's just say the actions are
all
public so the world
state is the
fixed entire state of the world so the
world state
would include the
your cards the public cards and your
opponent's cards
so the world state is sort of like a
super user
can look at all of the cards okay that's
the world state
no one knows the full world state but it
still exists
okay what we also need is uh so there's
the concept of actions
there's an action space uh which in
poker is something like you can bet
you can raise and so on so these are
your classic actions
and there is a transition function like
in
classic reinforcement learning so the
transition function depends on the world
state
and the action and it gives you the next
world state
and after an action each agent receives
a reward that is also a function of the
world state and the action
okay so important to note that this is
the reward you receive
but you don't know the you maybe know
the function but you don't know
the world state right so you can't
explicitly
sort of predict your reward you can
maybe predict the distribution
all right the next concepts are the
concepts of observation since we are in
an imperfect information game
an observation and the world state these
are not the same thing
like in in chess you need to look at the
board
and that's all there is there's all
there is to know
so the world state and the observation
are the same thing
here there is the concept of private and
public observations okay so public
observation
is like is what everyone
knows in each step whereas private
observations
are things that are just revealed to you
personally
in poker the private observation is
simply your two whole cards and the
public observation
is the middle cards so
this is the public observation and this
is your private observation
so the private observation is different
for each player while the public
observation is the same i guess you
could
model the public observation as simply
another player that doesn't get any hole
cards but
you know that that's a question of
semantics
all right the observations can also
include the actions that happen so far
it just for completeness if you
like you can you can get information
about hidden actions and so on
there's lots of mathematical freedom
here but just the concept is you have
private observations to each player
individually and then public
observations
the subscript i here always denotes a
individual player while you see there is
no such subscript in the public
in the public observations all right
the next concept is a history and a
history is pretty much what you think a
history or a trajectory
is a finite sequence of legal actions
and world states denoted by this so you
can see
it's simply the history of world states
and actions that
happened again no one
knows the history fully but it's still
it is still
the case and i know i know you can i
don't know quantum mechanics many worlds
theorem blah blah blah
um we'll just assume that whatever you
don't know
these these are fixed cards they're
actually there they have a value even
though
no one has looked at them yet so the
world state is
is defined even if you don't know it so
the first
real interesting concept here is called
an info state
okay so the info state is
like the world state or like the history
but it's conditioned on what an
individual player
knows okay the info state also called an
action observation history
for agent i is a sequence of an agent's
observations and actions
so you can see it's very much like a
history except
that it doesn't have the world states so
usually there will be the world state
here
you said no there is the observation for
player i
at each of the time steps okay and these
observations they include
public and private observations and
along with the actions but we'll say the
actions are public anyway
so an info state is basically
the history as it looks to player i
okay that's an info state in our
original game
we said that player two can't
distinguish
between the three nodes so if you look
at the three nodes individually
like this node one node two node three
these are three different world states
with three different histories
and to player two they are simply the
same
info state because all it all player two
knows is that player one has taken
some action it doesn't know which action
so
the observation that player two has is
exactly the same
therefore it can't distinguish so you
can see that the info state
is sort of the correct abstraction that
we're going to look at here
inco in you know in turn for if you look
for player one it looks different even
though for player one
it's also three different world states
it is also
three different info states okay because
player one
knows which action they have taken so
player one can decide
which of these three states um player
two is in
so player one this to player one this
corresponds to three different info
states
okay so the info states is always
conditioned on a
player and it is the sort of unit that
we'll
look at here right so
the info state um briefly the it
includes the observations and actions
for a given player and the observations
include the private
and the public observations the unique
info state corresponding to a history
for agent i
is denoted by this the set of histories
that corresponds to
some info state is denoted by large
h so as we said if you have an info
state
there are many different histories that
could have led
to the info state okay
so there are many different like there
may be for player two it looks like
three different histories that could
have happened lead to the same
info state okay that's but
any given history determined fully
determines the info state if i tell you
what happened
you can give me the info state for each
player you can say ah
uh player one played rocks therefore
player two is in
that info state and player one is in
that info state so that's why
there is a unique info state for each
history
but there is a set of histories for each
infostate
so the last um last concept from here
is a policy a policy
is again what you think it is so it is
something usually it's something that
maps from an
observation to an action or from a
history to an action or from a world
state to an action but here
it is a function necessarily that maps
from an
info state to a probability distribution
over action so two things important here
the input to the policy is an info state
since
the players they can't distinguish
between the world states as long as they
correspond to the same info state
therefore their policy necessarily must
be
taking an info state as an input so
player two's policy cannot depend on
what player one did
because it it can't distinguish
it can depend on the strategy of player
1 but not on the concrete action
the second thing is that we map to a
probability distribution over actions
now this is
usually the case in in rl if you frame
it as a general
principle however here it's going to be
quite important that this is always a
probability distribution very often in
these games
your strategy is probabilistic so there
is no
single best move in rock paper scissors
but the best
thing to do the best strategy is to play
each move with a one-third probability
or the modified version um at the
beginning
but it's important to see that
a a policy will output a probability
distribution and
i will also call this the strategy of a
player so the strategy
is going to be the the policy
and i i like to call it a strategy
because it's sort of
it's a kind of a plan what you would do
in each situation and we're going to see
that that is going to be a central theme
uh lifting in solving these games right
here using rebel
so policy profile is simply a tuple of
policies
uh so it's simply the policies of all
players that's the policy profile
um if you combine the policy profile
with some with some info state
or some history you can calculate the
expected value
so the expected value for a given
history uh
given that the players play policy pro
players play
pro policy profile pi so this is all
their strategies in history h and we're
going to look at player i
and its value so we can calculate the
expected
value of some policies
so i can i can given this function v i
can
input okay here's what happened and
here's how everyone's strategy
now tell me in expectation what the
first player is going to
net from this okay solving the value
function
is pretty much equivalent to solving the
game
um so if you if you give me a good value
function
i can solve the game by simply choosing
the next action that gives me the best
value function but there's a difficulty
we said okay we know pi strategies are
public
but we don't know what history we're in
right so even if you had the perfect
value function
i don't know what to input so this is
going to be a problem
all right the last thing is a nash
equilibrium you might know this term
a nash equilibrium is a policy profile
such that no agent can achieve a higher
expected value by switching to a
different policy
our goal here is going to be to find a
nash equilibrium
strategy for these games and the
rebel algorithm is going to provably
converge to a nash equilibrium
all right so okay there's also the
concept of a sub game a sub game is
defined by a root history
it's simply if you're in a it's simply a
game that starts at some
intermediate state that's a sub game
okay
alpha zero for example constructs sub
games
in fact it constructs these depth
limited sub games
because you only solve up to a certain
depth and at that point
you sort of ask your value estimator
what the value is
this is different in different uh things
like you can also do this this kind of
monte carlo estimation where you just
play one trace to the end
and so on but the notion is we
iteratively construct these
depth-limited sub-games
that means we play for a certain depth
and then
we evaluate at that depth
and the question is how are we going to
evaluate
okay so this
is all sort of the build up so we've
built up
that we can't deal with world states
like in classic games we need to deal
with
info states okay and
now with info states we have a problem
namely we can't use the alpha zero
algorithm again
because it will result in the thing on
the right okay
because if we simply ask our value
estimator our value estimator
even if it's perfect we it won't lead us
to the correct strategy
because the the value estimator here
is the wrong tool if we don't know
all of the information because of this
fact
that the value of a node doesn't only
depend on the downstream
actions but also depends on the upstream
strategies
okay so in an info state we can't
distinguish where we are
and that means our value estimations are
going to be
rather uh useless if we just apply this
algorithm straight forward
so we need a way to transform
a game where we don't know everything to
a game
where we do know everything okay it
sounds a bit weird
but that's exactly what we're going to
do right here so we're going to go
from world states to public belief
states
and um the world states
are sort of what we would like to have
but don't know
the public belief states those are going
to be
things that everyone
knows so if we go from world states to
public belief states we're going to be
in a situation again where everyone
knows
everything and therefore it is a perfect
information game it's
going to be a different game but if we
find the solution to this
different game we're going to end up
with the solution to
this to the original game
for that they ask you to imagine the
following game
consider a game in which one of 52
cards is privately dealt to each players
okay so you get a card your opponent
gets a card
one card by the way 52 for those of you
maybe in different parts of the world
that's the number of cards in a standard
card deck for
like poker and blackjack and so on um
i know different countries have
different things like in switzerland
you'll
very often find 36 cards to a deck
but just that's why because 52 appears
like a bit of a weird number
in any case so on each
turn a player chooses between three
actions
fold call or race so these are the the
sort of standard poker actions you can
either throw away your card if you don't
like it
you can uh match the bed of your
opponent or you can put in some money or
some more money yourself and at the end
i'm going to guess
yeah here eventually the game ends and
players receive a reward
so let's say whoever has the higher card
wins
the all the money in the middle now
consider
a modification of this game in which the
players cannot see their private cards
okay instead their cards are seen by a
referee
on the player's turn they announce the
probability
they would take each action with with
each
possible private card the referee then
samples an action and the players on the
player's behalf
from the announced probability
distribution for the player's
true private card this is
this is weird so usually you'd look at
your card
like i have an ace okay and then
you come up with a with a sort of
strategy you come up with
a policy you're going to say i'm going
to
raise with probability ace is pretty
good so i'm going to raise with
probability 0.7
i'm going to call with the probability
of
0.2 and i'm going to fold with a
probability of 0.1
so this here this would be a an
appropriate policy let's say
for getting an ace at the beginning
right
maybe this goes back and forth a bit and
you might change
because you might change your belief you
don't know what your opponent has
now the game changes namely
the game is going to be your opponent
gets a card and you get a card and you
don't get to look
at even your card so now you don't know
your opponent's card and you don't know
your
card but what you can do is
you can announce to the referee you can
say okay referee
i am going to do this if i have an ace
i'm going to raise with 0.7
call with 0.2 and fold with 0.1
if i have a king i'm going to okay i
need a bit more space
if i have a king i'm going to raise with
0.6 i'm going to call with point
three and i'm going to fold with point
one and so on until if i have a two
i'm going to raise with probability zero
i'm going to call with probability point
one
i'm going to fold almost all of it okay
so
you get to announce
your entire strategy to the referee
the referee who is a super user
or i don't know god so
or i don't know choose your favorite
deity um
seize everything seize all the cards
right the
referee will input will take this entire
table that you give it as input
it will go look at your card it will see
ah it's a king or it's an ace and it
will then
choose the appropriate sub table
here for you and then it will sample an
action from that
so instead of you looking and uh just
producing this table
you produce all the tables for all the
things
that you could have and then the referee
does the same thing for you
okay and so does your opponent and you
simply do this
so now you see it's a bit of a different
game
the the namely the actions are different
so the action is no longer
that you produce or sort of policy
is no longer you simply look at what you
have and you determine the probabilities
now the policy is
you spout out this table for
all the things you could have and in
each case for all the things you could
do
the important thing is so
they say okay at when the game starts
each player's belief distribution about
their private card is uniform
random and also about the opponent's
private card right however after each
action by the referee players can update
their belief distribution about
which card they are holding the obey's
rule
likewise players can update their belief
distribution about the opponent's
private card
through the same operation so it's
important to note that
this already happened before so even if
in the original game you would update
your belief about the opponent's private
card
according to bayes rule or whatever you
rule you want you will simply try to
infer what they have
um now the difference is you
also have to infer what you have uh
depending
on what actions the referee does so you
sort of treat yourself like
an like a player like a a different
player
like an opponent player that you don't
know the private cards of
thus the probability that each player is
holding each private card is common
knowledge among all players
at all times in this game so that makes
it
such that you you don't know your
opponent's card you don't know your card
you have to use sort of the same
algorithm
to determine what everyone has so that
means that
all the knowledge is shared like
no one knows the true private cards but
everyone
knows the same things okay so so if no
one knows
then everyone knows the same it's sort
of it's a bit like uh
it's a bit like probability socialism no
one has anything everyone's equal
sorry that's a that was a slight right
there
uh so the important thing they say the
critical insight
is that these two games are
strategically identical
okay that's the and that's very
surprising but if you think a bit about
it
it it becomes clear that your strategy
up here
is the same as down here you simply
don't fully announce it every time
explicitly but we we said anyway that
uh policies are public therefore this
game here
is equivalent to this game these are the
same games
but the latter contains no private
information
and is instead a continuous state and
action space
perfect information game okay while
players
do not announce their action
probabilities for each possible card in
the first game
we assume that all players policies are
common knowledge and therefore the
probability that a player would choose
each action for each possible card is
indeed known by all players
okay so um
and and this you can even lift the
restriction
uh that you know or don't know the
opponent's strategy so you don't
actually need
to know it but we'll simply assume that
everyone knows everyone's
strategy they just don't know their um
their private cards so the this is a new
game that we've constructed
where uh
it's it's a bit different right there
are different states and different
actions so the states that we deal with
in this game let's quickly analyze this
so what's
so we have state and action
in the in game one the state
is an info state so this is an info
state
and the action is going to be a
probability distribution over actions so
p of each of the actions okay in this
game down here
we have different states and different
actions now the states we're going to
get to in a minute
but what's the action the action is to
send a table
of all these probability distributions
in each case
like in case i have this in case i have
this in case i have this
so that's going to be the action the
action is going to be to send this
entire table
to the referee okay now what are the
states
this is this next section we refer to
the first game as the discrete
representation that's the
the top game and the second game as the
belief
representation an example above a
history in the belief representation
which we refer to as a
public belief state is described by a
sequence of public observations and 104
probabilities
the probability that each player holds
each of the 52 possible
private cards okay the so
this is going to be the state it's going
to be called a public belief state
and it's described by the sequence of
public observations and
104 probabilities so the probabilities
that probability that you have an ace
you have a king you have a queen and so
on like the
distribution over your cards and this
distribution of your opponent's cards
so it's simply the info it's like an
info state
of someone that just observes the game
that is going to be the public um
belief state okay likewise an
action is described by 156 probabilities
one per discrete action per private
card in general terms a pbs is described
by a joint probability distribution over
the agent's possible info states
you see it's a it's a distribution over
info states
so this state is a distribution
for each info state or they also call
this
a public belief state
so now we've gone from a
game that is imperfect information
to a game that is perfect information
okay
this is this is this has unknowns like
many like
oh this is different for each player but
here
all the information is known and these
two games are equivalent
it's just that you can see already the
problem like the
the states are way bigger because it's a
distribution over each state
that could be and the actions are also
way bigger
namely it's an one policy
for each state that you could be
in so these are massive amounts but
in theory that makes no difference right
so they say
since any imperfect information game can
be viewed as a perfect information game
consisting of public belief
representations or public belief states
in theory we could approximate a
solution of any
two-player zero-sum imperfect
information game by running a perfect
information
rl plus search algorithm on a
discretization of the belief
representation
okay so nothing stops you from simply
taking
this and running alpha zero
on this new thing on this new thing with
the states being public belief states
and the actions being descending around
of these giant tables and you might have
to discretize it as it says
but that's feasible um
so you can think of constructing this
game tree
but each node here is going to be a
public
belief state okay instead of
a world state like in alpha zero or like
an info state
like we started these imperfect
information games with and then
you can construct your tree down here
and then you know but this is infeasible
because these public belief states are
just too large
and the actions are also too large there
are so many actions
uh these are super high dimensional so
this is not
feasible um and we're going to
so they have to find a way
to do this thing but
um to to sort of do it in the domain of
the original game
and that's the i feel that's the entire
trick of this rebel paper is to take
the this idea let's do this search over
the public belief states
but somehow this this thing down here
um because what we need is we need the
values of these
right if we figure out the value of this
public belief state and the value of
this one right
this is beta1 this is of beta2
then we would know which action to take
and then
action is this huge thing but if we knew
the values of these
we would know which action to take
however
this is not feasible so we need to find
a way
to figure out these values using
the original formulation of the game
and that's what they do in the exact
next section right here
so they go on saying however as shown in
the example above believe representation
can be very high dimensional so
conducting search
is as is done in perfect information
games would be intractable they say
fortunately in two-player zero-sum games
these high-dimensional belief
representations are convex optimization
problems rebel leverages this fact via
conducting search via an iterative
gradient ascent-like
algorithm so i don't know what this
sentence means that the belief
representations are convex optimization
problems maybe this is misformulated or
i'm
just not understanding it uh well enough
in general this section here is a bit of
a mystery to me
um but i can sort of tell you what
what i understand of it okay
so they say rebels search algorithm
operates on super gradients
of the pbs value function at the
leaf nodes rather than on
pbs values directly this is the first
indication we don't want to
work so we want to construct this search
tree
and at the leaf nodes we need value
functions
right like in alpha zero now since we
operate on
public belief states we would need value
functions of public belief states
however rebel finds a way
to not do that specifically
the search algorithms require the values
of info states for pbs's
okay so they find a way to connect
the values of info states to the values
of public belief states
and just as a reminder an info state
is a state that as it looks to one
player
that could have many different histories
a public belief
state has all the info states
that could lead to the public
observation so all the info states that
you could be in right with all their
histories
here basically a distribution over all
these info states that
entire thing is one public belief
state now they are going
to say we can determine the value
of a public belief state so the value of
this is going to be equal
to and we can somehow approximate this
with the values of these thing here we
somehow
don't need the value of the entire
public leave state
we connect this to the values of the
individual
info states and that's i mean that's
done fairly easily because
you simply sum over so
um you can say the value of a given info
state
conditioned that you're in public belief
state beta is simply going to be kind of
the expectation
over all the histories that could lead
to this info state
multiplied by the value of each history
like you can have the value of a history
given some policy and therefore you can
approximate the value
at a given info state and this theorem
one here is where they connect
the value of a public belief state to
the value of an
info state so they say
for any public belief state for the
beliefs of
player 1 and player 2 infostates
respectively and any policy
pi star that is a nash equilibrium of
the sub game rooted at beta so now we
root sub games at public belief states
this thing holds right here so as you
can see this connects the value
of the public belief states this is what
we sort of need
um in order for the search algorithm to
work
it connects it to the value of an
info of info states and info states
are way lower dimensional than public
belief states so it connects
it connects the value of this
right here to the value of let's say
this
okay this this might be an info state
here s
and the value it connects the value of
the global public belief set to the
value of this particular info state
and it does so via this term right here
so this
term right here this is just the unit
vector in the direction of that
particular info state
and this here is a
super gradient of an extension of the
value function to unnormalize belief
distributions
as i understand it this g is
the gradient with respect
to probably beta1 if we care about s1
to v1 of beta
something like this um as i said this is
where i don't
100 uh see through it
but what i understand is that this
connects the value of the public belief
state this thing
to the value of the individual info
states that are
part of this public belief state so we
don't
need a value function for public belief
states
we can simply get away with learning a
value function
for the individual info states and
that's
what they do so the only the learned
part here in this algorithm this is the
first time we see like a neural network
since rebel's search algorithm uses
infostate values
rather than learn a pbs value function
rebel instead
learns an info state value function
so we're going to input a public belief
state yes and
we're going to get a value for each
info state we're going to get a value
here so we'll simply learn
a value function as sort of a vector
output you could also
input the public belief state and the
info state and get out a single number
i guess that would turn out to be the
same thing
okay so the infostate value function
directly approximates for each info
state the average
of the sampled values produced by rebel
at beta
so we're going to learn this in a sort
of bootstrap fashion like
like alpha zero does it a bit like
temporal difference learning
so what we're going to do in this
algorithm is we're going to start out
then we're going to construct this sort
of this subtree
and we're going to do this in the
discrete representation of the game
now that's the genius of the rebel
algorithm we're going to
sort of evaluate these things in the
discrete representation in the info
state representation
and then we're going to be able to
use what we find right here in order to
determine the value
of the next actions to take as far as i
can tell
okay so that there is only one thing
left to do right we need to know
how does how does this step here work so
we we said we want to do this research
over the public belief states but we
can't
it's too cumbersome um therefore
we can now we can
evaluate values of
a public belief state but we still need
to do to determine the policies
and that's where the self-play
reinforcement learning comes in
so bear with me for one second this is
going to kind of snap together
all that we've looked at so far in this
section
we describe rebel and prove that it
approximates a nash equilibrium
at the start of the game a depth limited
sub game
rooted at the initial public belief
state is generated
this sub game is solved by running t
iterations of an iterative equilibrium
finding algorithm
in the discrete representation of the
game but using the learned
value network to approximate leaf values
on every iteration
okay so it might seem a bit a bit
complicated but what we're going to do
is we're going to
here is what i think happens and this is
a bit unclear to me we're going to
take a any public beliefs that we find
ourselves in they call they tell the the
beginning
of the game but any any public belief
state okay
so the public belief state is maybe here
and it contains many different info
states
now what i
think happens here is that they may be
sampling one of the info states i don't
know or they may
input the public belief states at the
beginning this is unclear to me but then
they're going to
solve the game in the discrete
representation so they're going to use a
classic solver
to solve the game up to a limited depth
okay so this limited depth is going to
be
sort of these steps in into the future
this is going to be in the classic
representation so classic states and
classic actions now the
solver that they use for this is
counterfactual regret minimization
this is a solver that works with
infostates
okay so you can actually use cfr to
solve poker
however you can't solve all of poker
because the game is too big
right so but you can solve a sub game
provided that you have good value
estimates here
at the end so that since they use cfr
that leads me to believe they don't use
the entire
public belief state as an input to cfr
but they either
maybe sample an info state or they
actually sample
one particular history that happened um
that is unclear to me however what they
do is
they they do this they solve the sub
game
using cfr and then
out of that they get a strategy okay so
here
you ask your solver what should i do
given you know given my estimates of the
values right here
and the cfr will say i know what you
should do here is a strategy
here is a policy that you should do now
if this were
alpha zero if this were fully observable
then
you would be done right you you'd say
okay i'm done cool
um that's what i'm going to do however
what we saw above is that
um your values right here your values
down here
they are dependent on what comes
before you specifically they are
dependent
on this strategy okay now cfr
needs some sort of an initial strategy
okay and it outputs a
best strategy for the given values but
now that you have another strategy these
values here
they are no longer valid and you
computed the strategy with the values so
what you're going to do is you're going
to
plug in you're going to use this thing
to compute new values
okay more values you're going to
construct another
c or the same sub game with new values
and then use
cfr again to solve that and that will
give you
the next policy for these values but
then the values change again
and so on now this is going to converge
eventually but you're going to have to
run a couple of iterations of this
for this to converge in fact i believe
it's the
the running average or the average
that's going to
converge um but you're going to
solve a number of these sub games
okay until you reach the actual best
strategy
and you're going to do that down the
game tree so from this
thing you're going to construct sub game
you're going to construct
one two three updating the values
solving it and then once you have it you
sample some state in between
from that you're going to solve this sub
game again
one time two time three time and so on
until convergence
and so on so this multiple solving of
the same sub game
that's what we have to do so
it is the price we have to pay for
solving the game
in the discrete representation because
we can't solve it
in the belief representation because
it's too big
there we would only have to solve it
once but here we have to solve it
multiple times
so this is the entire algorithm right
here you can see
while the while we're not in a terminal
state
we're going to construct a sub-game and
initialize some some policy
and then for each step we're going to do
first um sorry we also set the leaf
values
so this setting of leaf values that's
simply
um forwarding like
if i know the policy
i can go set the leaf values using my
neural network
right my neural network can tell me what
the value at each of the leaf nodes are
that's what we train it for
so in the set leaf values there is a
neural network you see this
by the fact that there are parameters
right here
and then we're going to do repeatedly
the following two things
update policy so this here
is where we use the solver cfr so we
determine the best policy given the
current value estimations
and then we're going to set new
values given the policy so see cfr
it will take in the last policy and it
will output the next
policy and set leaf values
will in will take in these parameters
which meaning this here
that's going to be some kind of mlp or
neural network
and we're going to do this then we're
going to
loop back again and do the same thing
solve the game set new values solve the
game set new values solve the game
set new values okay eventually
by aggregating all of this information
we are going to
be able to compute the expected value
and that's going to be the value of the
public belief
state altogether and as we said if we
know
the value we can sort of take the best
action
in fact here i believe that the policy
that comes out
this average policy is the nash
equilibrium and we can simply sample an
action
from that all right
that's what they describe here they use
we describe rebel assuming the
counterfactual regret minimization
decomposition cfrd algorithm
is used okay this is a depth limited
version of cf of cfr
that's an entire research direction by
itself right here
counterfactual regret minimization is
simply used as sort of the inner solver
kind of a helper function to call
and that thing by itself is an entire
entire algorithm it's like a very
complicated algorithm
okay on each iteration cfrd
determines a policy profile in the sub
game next the value of
every discrete representation leaf node
is set to this and this is this is the
neural network right so
we're going to use the neural network to
set the leaf node values of the discrete
representation
okay um this means that the value of a
leaf node during search is conditional
on the policy
thus the leaf node value change
every iteration given pi and the leaf
node values each info state has a
well-defined values this vector of
values is stored
and next cfrd chooses a new policy
profile in the
process repeats for t iterations
all right that's the rebel algorithm
and they also describe how they actually
sample data for learning with the
exploration
and they also show that running
algorithm one
with t iterations of cfr in each subgame
will produce a value approximator
that has an error of at most this for
any pbs that could be encountered during
play
okay so they're going to say that the
value approximator
given that it is sort of idealized
will actually converge to a good value
approximator
if you uh sample it depending on how
many
iterations of cfr you do but you can see
that the more iterations you do the
better of an approximation you get
and if you have a good value estimator
as we already said you
uh basically have solved the game um
the last thing is that they determine
now what do we do
at test time you might not have thought
of this this this was this
seems sort of obvious if you know alpha
zero but
they determine that at inference time
you can simply
run this same algorithm except you you
don't want to produce training data from
it and you don't want to learn anything
you simply want to run this algorithm
too if you run that algorithm at test
time
that will actually give you a nash
equilibrium so that's theorem three
right here
if algorithm run one runs a test time
with no of policy exploration
value network with error at most this
and this and was trained as described in
theorem two
with t iterations of that then the
algorithm
plays a this kind of approximation nash
equilibrium where c1
and c2 are game specific constants
okay so you can see right here that the
nash equilibrium is going to be perfect
depending on how many iterations you do
and depending on i believe how accurate
your neural network is yes your value
network
error okay if you make that smaller your
nash equilibrium is going to be
better pretty pretty cool so that was
the algorithm they do a bunch of
experiments where they say
what kind of network uh they if they use
the value net or not
if they use self play or not and
uh they can also introduce a policy net
uh i believe for initializing
or or searching more effectively
they compare against previous things
like deepstack libratus and so on
they do beat top humans as you can see
poker has been for a long time kind of
an not so solved game by machine
learning but this area has been over for
a while
right now and they do release the code
of um i believe of the liar's dice so
they
have the code released for rebel and the
implementation for liars dice
but not for uh poker because
that's what they discuss in the broader
impact statement so let's quickly look
at
broader impact then we're done so
i just to say i love this broader impact
statement
it is um it describes
like it praises the paper so it's kind
of more
advertisement for the paper uh it
it does almost like no harm to
the paper itself to its reputation
it is actually accurate so this broader
impact statement actually makes
tangible predictions and it doesn't go
beyond
the or it mostly doesn't go beyond the
tangible things you can say about this
algorithm and it
actually has as a conclusion and
action that they take so
and further it is nothing like what
the original specification of broader
impact statement says
and that makes me happy so
good job on this one we believe rebel is
a major step towards general agreement
finding algorithm yada yada so they say
if this is um this is good because many
things
are sorry sort of these kind of uh
games if you can extend it to
multi-agent and so on so this is the
technology good
section but then the bad section is
interesting the most immediate risk
posed by this work is its potential for
cheating in recreational games such as
poker
while a algorithm already exists they
say why why they are better why this
particular algorithm
could be used for cheating where the
others can't
be done so easily by the way this
algorithm um
by nature of performing these searches
over and over again
it needs a lot of compute like it needs
a lot of compute the learning isn't the
problem the problem is performing these
searches
over and over and over again um
yeah so it's not super easy to replicate
like don't
don't try this at home however if they
were to release
the pre-trained network that would make
it easy
and they also say if they release the
code that would maybe make it easier to
cheat
if you can simply run maybe you know you
don't have the hardware but
given massive poker winnings who knows
retraining the algorithms to account for
arbitrary cheek styles
this is a requires more computation as
feasible in real time that's about the
other algorithms
however rebel can compute a policy for
arbitrary stack size and arbitrary
bet sizes in seconds so that's at
inference time
partly for this reason we have decided
to not to release the code for poker
we instead open source our
implementation for liars dice a
recreational game that is not played
competitively
by humans okay so it's a
concrete prediction of the impact of the
of this work it has a concrete action
to kind of its conclusion and it doesn't
dabble in
who know if uh if we now
solve these two player imperfect
information games then
surely in the future bombs will fly
in stuff like this um yeah good job on
this again
all right so this was the overview
of the paper we started with the notion
of info states and info states are kind
of like
states in classic reinforcement learning
and we determined that we can't really
use the sort of alpha zero
a way of doing things because the value
of info states not only depends on
downstream things
but also on upstream things and the
values here
yeah that makes the values at the end of
the tree
not constant and that means
uh we can't really use that as we saw in
this poker thing
then we converted the game from an
infostate representation to a public
belief state representation
where now it's sort of it's again a
everyone knows everything game
therefore we could use the alpha zero
way of doing things
however since the states and the actions
are so large because it consists of
these giant
tables of numbers we can't use the alpha
zero for computational reasons
luckily they find a way to connect
the value function of public belief
states to the value functions of
info states and therefore we can use
a solver in the classic in the discrete
representation
to approximate or to to um
to use in this search procedure as long
as
we run it multiple times and sort of
keep updating
its values by doing that um
we can use this in this self play simply
iteratively doing this
in each step and we can
use bootstrapping uh and play
as we said self play between two agents
and that will
provably converge to a good value
function
and to a nash equilibrium all right
that was the paper thanks for listening
i'll see you next time
bye bye